[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHER YOUNG: Please give
a very, very warm Google
welcome to Madeleine.
[APPLAUSE]
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: Thank you.
Thank you.
So Heather, I want to
thank you for telling
everybody who I am because
not everybody always knows.
Not long ago, I was
coming back from China
and Chicago was the
first port of entry.
And I was there getting
undressed for the security
people.
And I put my stuff down
on the conveyor belt.
And the lady behind
me said, so where
did you get all those
screwtop bottles?
My bottles all leak.
And I said, well,
The Container Store.
And then I was going
through the magnetometer.
And the TSA guard looks at me.
And he says, "oh
my god, it's you."
[LAUGHTER]
"I'm from Bosnia.
And we all love you in Bosnia.
And if it weren't for you,
there wouldn't be a Bosnia.
And you're welcome in Bosnia.
And they said, can I have
my picture taken with you?
And I said, sure.
So the line gets all screwed up.
And I go back to get my stuff.
And the lady of
the screwtop bottle
says, so what exactly
happened here?
And I said, well, I used to
be the Secretary of State.
And she said, "of Bosnia?"
[LAUGHTER]
HEATHER YOUNG: Well, I've
also heard you talk about
that sometimes you're not
necessarily recognized
by millennials and that you have
a different name for your age
group.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: Well, I do.
It's called a perennial.
But one of the things
is this is a book tour.
And we call it the
Antiques Roadshow.
HEATHER YOUNG: Well
then, I fit right in.
So the book--
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: By the
way, I have to correct you.
HEATHER YOUNG: Oh, I'm sorry.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: They've just
put me number one on "The New
York Times" Best Sellers, so--
HEATHER YOUNG: I
was about to say--
[APPLAUSE]
It debuted at number one.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: Yes.
HEATHER YOUNG: Yes, absolutely.
And so you say some may
view this book and its title
as alarmist--
good.
Why do you say that?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
Well, because the reason
I wrote it is because
I am concerned
about what I see in
the United States
but also internationally.
And some of it is
my own background.
Because I was born in
1937 before World War II.
And I was born in
Czechoslovakia.
And as a result of an agreement
between the British and French
with the Germans and
Italians over the heads
of the Czechoslovaks,
the Munich Agreement
was signed, which
was a watershed event
in the history of the
country where I was born.
And basically, the country
was sold down the river.
And the thing that had happened
was that a German minority had
been propagandized by
a man, Konrad Henlein,
who was a disciple of Hitler's.
And then the Nazis
marched in March, 1939.
And my father had been
a Czechoslovak diplomat.
And we fled to England.
And then later,
when he went back
and we came to the
United States--
because the communists had
taken over Czechoslovakia.
And I know of my own
personal family history what
the results of fascism are.
And later, I found out that
26 members of my family
had died in the Holocaust.
And so I thought that
it was worth examining
what fascism was.
And the book is really
quite historical in terms
of looking at a lot of
the history of Mussolini
and Hitler, and then
currently the things
that I see that are going
on in Europe and here.
HEATHER YOUNG: So I saw a study
that was cited in "The New York
Times" recently that highlighted
some really surprising gaps
in people's memory about
not only these times,
but also about the Holocaust.
And it mentioned that
something like 52% of Americans
wrongly think that Hitler
came to power through force,
that nearly 66% of
millennials couldn't
say what Auschwitz was.
Do you think that this will
make a difference in the memory
of the American people?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
Well, hope so.
Because I think that--
you did mention I
was a professor.
And I do believe that we
need to understand history.
And so putting it
into that context--
by the way, the thing,
as I was doing research
for the book, that blew my mind
is that the countries that I
was dealing with, beginning
with Italy and then Hitler,
and then also what is going
on now in Poland and Hungary,
and in Turkey, the
Philippines, Venezuela, Russia,
is that, in fact, people--
except for Russia-- have always
been either elected or got
their power constitutionally.
King Emanuel of Italy
gave it to Mussolini.
And then also Von Henneberg
had asked Hitler to take over.
And otherwise, in
those other countries,
the people were elected.
Which is why I think that
one has to really think
about how this happens.
Mussolini had a great
quote which I love to use,
which is that "if you pluck a
chicken one feather at a time,
people don't notice
the squawks."
And it's that kind
of a thing that
is a warning very deliberately.
Because I think that there are
various elements of fascism
that are evident.
HEATHER YOUNG: So with the
slow plucking of the chicken,
is that what people
talk about when
they say you shouldn't be
normalizing some things that
are going on?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: Exactly.
And I do think it's that idea
that we'll all get over it,
and normalizing.
And so some of the
characteristics of fascism
are that--
and it's not easy to define.
I say in the book that people
use the term fascist quite
loosely, kind of
accusing anybody
you disagree with as a fascist.
Declan is a very nice
boy, but at some point
he might call you a fascist
if you don't lend him the car,
you know.
So I think that it's a term
that's kind of thrown around.
And yet there are aspects
of it that we need to note.
And one, for instance, is that
the leader identifies himself
with a large group
that he says he
represents to the exclusion of
the rights of the other group.
So it's very much
an "us versus them."
And then the leader exacerbates
that division even more.
Also, if the leader has decided
that democratic institutions
don't work--
and one of the things we're
seeing both in the United
States and in Poland, for
instance, and Hungary,
is the demonization of
the judicial branch--
not just packing it, but in
terms of just deprecating
what they do.
Or using media in a way
to propagandize people,
not ever being able to have
any kind of a civil discourse
with anybody.
And then really willing to--
I mean, the definition
of a fascist leader
is somebody who has this
identification with one group
and then ultimately is willing
to use any force at all
to get his way.
And so it's kind of
a bully with an army.
So those are the
characteristics.
And I do think
that I'm concerned
about some of the feathers
that are being plucked here.
HEATHER YOUNG: So when you refer
to democratic institutions,
what does that mean for people
who may not have been here
their whole lives?
What is a democratic
institution?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: A
democratic institution
is one that is created by a
constitution, for one thing.
But then also exists,
if it's the elected
part of the government, on the
basis of citizens understanding
who are the people that
are running for office,
and that they are
there to be removed
if they don't do the job.
So it's very much an
interactive aspect
with the people of a country.
And one of the things that
has concerned me an awful lot
is that--
this may sound overly
political theory--
that the social contract
has been broken.
Because for
centuries, people have
been willing to give up some
individual rights in order
to be protected by the state.
And what that does is create
some mutual obligation
so that the state
is supposed to make
some provision for highways,
and schools, and various things.
But in return, the people are
supposed to be active citizens,
and vote, and keep track
of who has been elected.
So that is what democracy
is about-- the involvement
of the people in the
democratic institutions.
HEATHER YOUNG: So when
you talk about fascism,
how is it different from
other forms of government
like authoritarianism?
Where's the line between those?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: Well,
the interesting part
is that for the most
part, authoritarianism is
something that comes top-down.
To some extent, monarchies
are authoritarian,
or the current
Saudi government is.
What is interesting
about fascism
is this linkage of
bottom-up and top-down.
Because it is
based on a disquiet
among a group of people.
And there are people that
are unhappy over their lot
economically probably, or
some other ways that they're
being discriminated against.
And then the fascist
leader will take advantage
of this bottom-up aspect
to then impose, top-down,
a rule that ends up in
some form of violence,
and the leader is
convinced that he's
above the law, and those other
aspects that I mentioned.
And then there is
usually some form
of violence involved in it.
But it's what makes it
different from authoritarian--
Every fascist is a dictator.
Not every dictator is a fascist.
HEATHER YOUNG: These
leaders, though,
don't exist in a vacuum.
And so when you think about
things like-- in the US,
you could think about our
Congress as an example.
Isn't there a
responsibility there
to help keep things in check?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
Very much so.
And I think that's one of the
things we also have to look at.
I have a series of
questions at the end
of the book which really are--
what kind of
leaders do you want?
What are you looking for?
Are you participating at all
in what needs to be done?
And so I do think what
is disappointing--
by the way, I think that
our form of government
is fascinating in so many ways,
in the checks and balances,
and various aspects.
I had worked on Capitol Hill
for Senator Muskie from Maine.
I then went and worked
in the White House
doing congressional relations.
And so I think
executive-legislative,
the interaction of
those two branches,
is incredibly interesting.
And there are a
lot of people who
think we should have a
parliamentary system where
the party that wins
the parliament then
gets to name the
executive branch.
We have a different system,
the presidential system.
But the checks and
balances are important.
And I have to say, I am
disappointed in the way
that this Congress
has been acting.
Because we, in the
past, have occasionally
had what's known as a
do-nothing Congress.
But this one seems to
be really gridlocked.
And so then it gives more
credibility to those who say,
well, nothing
works in Washington
so let's do something else.
And so that is one of the
things that really worries me.
And so we all know the saying,
"see something, say something."
I've decided to add
to it, "do something."
And on my to-do
list is to really
encourage people to be much
more involved politically,
either to run for
office themselves
or be supportive
of those that they
agree with to run for office.
Because Congress--
if they're not
doing the job they're
supposed to, they can leave.
And I have been so moved by the
children that were marching.
They originally started
with the Florida group.
But there are a lot of them.
And they want change.
And so I think that
it's important to see
what they're doing.
By the way, there isn't a
book or a speech given that
doesn't quote Robert Frost.
So I will do that.
He said, "the older I get,
the younger the teachers are."
And the bottom
line is they are--
the kids really are there.
They want gun
sanity so that they
don't have to go to
school in flack jackets.
And so I do think that
we need to be much more
active in terms of--
if the members of Congress
aren't doing anything,
then there are other
people that will.
HEATHER YOUNG: When people
think about becoming more active
in our democracy, a
lot of times you'll
see that people are
clicking on or signing
some petition or another.
Are those really effective?
Or when you tell
people that they
need to go do something,
what specifically should they
be doing?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: I do
think the following thing--
that petitions do work.
I do think part of it, having
been a recipient of some,
if they are letters that
all sound exactly the same,
I think people think
they're motivated.
But are they real?
But I do think it's
very important to let
your member of Congress
know what you want
and what you don't want.
And there are so many
ways of doing it now.
But I also do think
that one of the
"do something" is not only,
as I said, run for office,
but also be supportive in a
number of different ways--
door knocking.
But also what I find stunning
is that not everybody votes.
And some people can't
even get registered.
And you mentioned
that I was chairman
of the board of the National
Democratic Institute.
I have gone abroad a lot
to monitor elections.
And what has happened
is people there
stand in either the
hot sun or the rain
in order to be able to vote.
They see it as a privilege.
And we aren't doing that enough.
And I think that there are
too many people who have
said "my vote doesn't count."
That is not true.
My first vote for president was
for John Kennedy in Chicago.
And it counted.
And I do think that
just generally--
and it isn't just
the top, the federal.
I think it's very
important for people
to support their mayors, city
councils, state governments,
and kind of see the depth
of American democratic
institutions, and get out
there and do something.
Because I think then it
is our responsibility
if we've given up our
privilege of being citizens.
HEATHER YOUNG: Why do
you think that we're
seeing this increase
in authoritarianism
in various places
around the world now?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: Well,
I think the following thing
that's happened-- and we're
living in an incredibly
complicated time.
You all are part of
it in so many ways.
I've kind of talked
about that there's
three eras since the
end of World War II.
The first era was the Cold War.
And the world was divided
into the red, and the red,
white, and blue, and that we
were fighting the communists.
And that somehow was
easier to understand.
There was one enemy--
this communist ideology.
Then what happened was after
the fall of the Berlin Wall,
there was incredible excitement
about the possibility
of doing different
things and trying
to see how modern technology
worked and operated, in a way.
That was the time of the
Clinton administration.
And we kept thinking that life
could be really different.
President Clinton kept building
bridges to the 21st century
and trying to figure out what
the system would be like.
Then 9/11 happened.
And I think that was
truly a watershed moment
for this country.
And all of a sudden, we're in
that post-9/11 period which has
operated, to a great extent, on
the basis of the fear factor.
We can't operate on fear factor.
The United States has to
operate on the hope factor.
But the thing that
has happened--
there are a couple
of global trends
that have their downside.
And the first one
is globalization.
And globalization is
not a four-letter word.
We all are great beneficiaries
of globalization,
the possibility of
traveling and buying
things from different
countries and knowing people
from a variety of places.
But it does have a downside.
It's faceless.
And so people feel that
they don't have an identity.
And we all are entitled to
an identity, either ethnic,
or linguistic, or religious.
And that's fine.
And I think patriotism is a
very good sense and feeling.
What is bad is if my
identity hates your identity.
And then that turns
into nationalism
and hyper-nationalism, which is
very dangerous, and is used by
demagogues to motivate
people who feel displaced.
And one of the things
that has happened
is the other megatrend,
which is technology.
And I think that
we all thought--
and you all clearly do--
that it's this magical new
concept that can really work.
And it does bring
people together
in the most amazing way.
I always like to talk about
the woman farmer in Kenya that
doesn't have to walk miles
anymore to pay her bills.
She can just use her phone
and make that happen.
But it also has a downside
because it has disaggregated
people's voices in many ways.
And people live in their
own little echo chamber.
And one of the examples
to use, for instance,
is what happened in Egypt
during the Arab Spring.
People were motivated by social
media to go to Tahrir Square.
And they were very excited.
And they didn't like
their government.
But then-- and people are
surprised whenever I say this--
I think the election
was held too soon.
The Muslim Brotherhood
was organized,
and the people in
Tahrir Square were not.
They had been listening
to their own--
whoever they wanted
to listen to.
And so the Muslim
Brotherhood gets elected.
And things are a mess in Egypt.
And then what happens is--
I made up this mythical man
who lives outside of Cairo,
wants to come in to open
a stall in the souk.
And he can't get by the
traffic because Tahrir Square
is a mess.
And so he says
"screw it" in Arabic.
And then he says, I want order.
So then what happens is
General Sisi comes in
and they have order
with a capital O.
So what has happened is
this disquiet in societies
then creates this disorder.
The democratic institutions
are too slow to work.
And then the authoritarian
who wants, in fact,
to take advantage of all
of that and exacerbates it,
and that's how you get to
authoritarian government.
Because the democratic
institutions
are not operating fast enough.
Now, I stole this line
from somebody out here
that I think describes
the situation perfectly.
People are talking
to their governments
on 21st century technology.
The governments listen to them
on 20th century technology,
and provide 19th
century responses.
So there is no faith
in the institutions.
And that's what we're
involved in now.
And what does need to be
done in this third era
is to understand the
magic of new technology,
prepare people for
working in it and not
feeling that they are
useless, and then try
to sort out what
the institutions are
that go with it.
So I think this is a massively
disarrayed period, but one
that offers huge opportunity
to the millennials
while the perennials
keep talking.
HEATHER YOUNG: Well, you've got
the ear of a lot of the people
who are creating the
22nd century knowledge.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
Absolutely, yep.
HEATHER YOUNG: From
personal experience,
I remember watching
the Berlin Wall fall.
But for me, because
I hadn't lived
through its going up and
all that that entailed,
that was a history
lesson for me.
And I didn't have
a connection to it
the same way that my
parents or grandparents did.
And talking to my son
the other day about 9/11,
it occurred to me that--
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
He didn't know?
HEATHER YOUNG: --he will
never feel that connection,
that it will always be
a historic exercise.
And so is there a way that we
can really help millennials
or whoever that may not
have lived through some
of these events really
get a deeper sense of them
and a connection to them
so that they're not just
an academic exercise?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
Well, I really
do think that it is
important to know history.
And you know, there's
always that thing--
if you don't know history,
you're bound to repeat it.
And it's never quite the same.
But I do think it's
important to explain history.
And I think to an extent, it can
be explained in terms of people
that the younger people
might know or know
about their grandparents.
I think it's very important
to personalize it.
But in the end,
history is history.
And one has to read
it and understand it,
but also not just
to know the facts
but to know the
implications of the facts.
You had mentioned Auschwitz.
All right, so it's a place.
But you have to
understand that people
were sent there against their
will, and put in gas chambers,
and killed.
And that was as a result
of fascists that believed--
and this is the important
part about all of this--
there are economic
problems in every country.
And it's bound to happen.
And technology is miraculous,
there's no question.
And there always has
been some new technology.
But it does disrupt things.
There's no question about that.
And it does create divisions.
And I think that unless one
deals with the divisions,
then it's only
going to get worse.
But the demagogue leader that
does work off of the bottom
takes a look at it
and first of all uses
nationalism-- this is our
people that are doing this.
And nationalism can spur people
to good things and bad things.
A fascist leader spurs
them in a bad direction.
And then what happens is there
always has to be somebody
to blame for this.
So there are the scapegoats.
And by the fascists,
it was the Jews.
And now it is the immigrants.
And so if you look
at what's happening
in Hungary, for instance--
and history makes
a big difference.
And Hungary is an
interesting place.
By the way, this is
the 100th anniversary
of the end of World War
I. And the countries
in Central and Eastern
Europe came into existence
at that point.
And they were based
on national identity.
I was born in
Czechoslovakia, as I've said.
And it turns out the first
president of Czechoslovakia
married an American.
Her name was Charlotte Garrigue.
And he, Tomas Garrigue
Masaryk, took her maiden name
as his middle name.
So imagine-- this was a wedding
at the end of the 19th century.
And the Czechoslovak
constitution
is based on the
American Constitution
with one difference--
it had equal rights
language in it in 1918.
But the thing that
is interesting--
Hungary was the
Austro-Hungarian Empire.
But all of a sudden,
there was this country--
Hungary.
And then at the
end of World War I,
there was a treaty,
the Treaty of Trianon,
that actually Hungary,
having been an empire,
became a smaller country.
And I did a set
of surveys in '91.
And we asked the country,
all across Europe-- people,
do you believe a
piece of your country
is in the neighboring country?
And I'll never forget.
80% of Hungarians thought
a piece of their country
was in another country.
So they are dissatisfied.
And Orban, the current
prime minister,
is blaming the migrants.
And he only wants Hungarians.
He doesn't want anybody
that's not a Hungarian.
And they are now the scapegoats.
So part of the
fascist ideology here
is hyper-nationalism
and a scapegoat.
That's what Auschwitz was about.
HEATHER YOUNG: The
book covers a number
of historical and
present-day examples.
A lot of those
examples ended in war.
Please tell me you have
some good examples of where
they didn't have to go to
some kind of a World War II
to come back from nationalism.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: Well
actually, one was Argentina.
You know, "Don't Cry
For Me, Argentina."
HEATHER YOUNG: I just
found some good music.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
But for the most part,
unfortunately, they do end
in some kind of violence.
Which is why what concerns
me is this whole business
about the fear factor.
And I think that
compels us to think
we have to destroy something.
Whereas I think that if there's
some rational discussion
with people, it's
possible not to.
But unfortunately,
a lot of them do end
in some kind of violence.
And I think that is something
to be concerned about.
HEATHER YOUNG: You
wrote your dissertation
on the role of information
in political change
and the importance
of the free press
not only to access information
but then to access trustworthy
information.
I've noted a couple
of examples recently
where even members of
Congress have cited things
from satirical websites thinking
that they were genuine news
stories as they were having
discussions about legislation.
What do you do to
get information?
And how do you know that you're
getting good information?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: Well, it is
difficult. There's no question.
And let me just
say, I have always
been interested in the
role of information
and political change.
And my dissertation was about
the Czechoslovak press in 1968.
What was interesting at
that point was the people
knew something and the official
press didn't print it ever.
Because the people had
gotten their information
from Radio Free Europe
and Voice of America.
But basically, they were
spreading that kind of news
among themselves.
And it wasn't until
the newspapers
became uncensored and
were able to print it
that it was regarded as truth.
There's also always
been some technology.
So I wrote about
the Polish press
at a certain point, solidarity.
The big invention at that
point was the microcassette.
And what had happened was Lech
Walesa would go to a factory.
And they would tape it.
And then they'd send
the microcassette
to another factory and kind of
kept the whole thing moving.
Then, to go back
to Tahrir Square,
the opposite of what had
happened in Czechoslovakia
happened in Tahrir Square.
The people did
not have the truth
because they were listening to
their own little echo chamber.
But the journalists actually
were writing the truth.
And now they've all
been put in jail.
But the bottom line
was it's whoever
can get at the facts
that make the difference.
I think the issue
now is the following.
And that is that--
first of all, I can be
accused of being a relativist.
I think it is hard to
find the absolute truth.
But the way I get
my information is I
read a number of
different newspapers,
just the way if
you're doing research
you actually have to look at
a number of different sources.
And while the interpretation
may be slightly--
I read "The Washington
Post," "The New York Times,"
"The Wall Street Journal,"
and "The Financial Times"
every day.
And I'm able to
kind of combine it.
Then I Google everything.
But the bottom line
is that I do think
one has to do some
comparative aspect,
and then really try to figure
out what the source is.
And that's where you
guys are also helpful.
But I do think sourcing
takes more work.
And I think that people do get
fooled by something, thinking
that it is the
truth, at which point
you have to check everything.
But the bottom line is I think
it is very important also
to read and listen to
things you disagree with.
So you should all be very
glad you live here and not
in the other Washington.
Because I drive there.
And I listen to right-wing
radio as I drive.
And I yell and scream a lot.
And some day I'm going to hit
something or get arrested.
But I do think
people need to listen
to things they disagree with.
HEATHER YOUNG: I had
a negotiation teacher
once that said, you
really need to be
able to make the argument
for the other side.
If you can't, then you don't
understand it well enough.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: And I
have to say, I teach a course.
I say foreign policy is just
trying to get some country
to do what you want.
That's all it is.
And so what are
the tools you have?
So my course is called the
National Security Toolbox.
I have my students
write short memos
because nobody in the
government reads 35-page papers.
And besides, you can get
a 35-page paper on Google.
And so the bottom line is I
make my students deliberately
do what you just said.
They propose something.
And I tell them they have to
do the argument against what
they have proposed and
also look at contingencies.
By the way, our
current president
would flunk my course.
HEATHER YOUNG: Where does social
media fit in your toolbox?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
Social media fits
more and more in terms
of, just generally,
what the role of information is.
Because you can't operate
without information.
And I think the issue
here is that one
can make various plans.
But unless you have
information, you'll go wrong.
And that is the example
of the war in Iraq.
The wrong information
was out there.
And a lot of things
were based on it.
And so I think that social
media plays a huge role.
And I'm still trying to
sort this out-- the pros
and cons of social media.
Because it has connected us
all in an incredible way.
But it also has
created a whole new set
of issues in terms of what
the regulations are about it.
We certainly are seeing that
now, how one has freedom
but at the same time,
there are some ways
where it's terrible if the
wrong thing all of a sudden
gets circulated.
It has a lot of paradoxes in
it, which is the millennials
and the younger ones put
all of the information
about themselves on something.
And then they wonder why people
know everything about them.
And so there are all
kinds of aspects of it.
But I do think
that it's obviously
the major aspect in
terms of connectivity
now, and an amazing force
both positive and negative.
And so I think that
all of you have
a great responsibility with it.
HEATHER YOUNG: You
remain the highest
sitting US government
official to have
met with a North Korean leader.
Long before you
traveled there in 2000,
there was a lot of preparation
work that went into that.
I'd like to just
get your reaction
to some of the recent news in
terms of the recent trip that
was taken by the
Secretary of State
nominee and the plans for the
president to meet Kim Jong-un.
With the changes that have taken
place at the State Department
and the changes in
funding, and everything
that's happened over the
last couple of years,
are they in a good
place to be able to have
those kinds of meetings?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
Well, yes and no.
First of all, let me say--
during the Clinton
administration,
we spent an inordinate amount
of time on North Korea.
It started, frankly, at the
beginning of the administration
when the North Koreans said
they were going to pull out
of the nonproliferation treaty.
I was up at the UN at the time.
And I won't go through
the whole history,
but we spent a lot
of time on something
called The Agreed
Framework, which
was going to limit their nuclear
capabilities in exchange for us
selling them heavy fuel and
doing a lightwater reactor
probe.
Anyway, it kept going
on in complications
so that President
Clinton in '98, '99
asked, by then, former
Secretary of Defense
Bill Perry to do a complete
review of our North Korean
policy.
So that already was an
incredible amount of work.
And he basically
went to North Korea
and told them this was
a fork in the road time,
that either they were
going to negotiate
about what they were doing or
we were prepared to use force.
They chose negotiation.
So then what happened
was that the number two
guy came to the United States.
And we were in the
Oval Office when
he handed to President
Clinton an invitation for him
to go to North Korea.
And so President Clinton wisely
said, yes, well, maybe I'll
come some time but this
has to be prepared.
I'm sending the
Secretary of State.
They were not
thrilled about that.
But the bottom line is,
getting ready for the trip we
had already done an
incredible amount of work.
And even with that, we didn't
have a lot of intelligence
on Kim Jong-il, the father.
And so I talked to Kim Dae-jung,
the president of South Korea
who had met with him.
And it was evident--
and our intelligence, by the
way said that Kim Jong-il
was crazy and a pervert.
I found out he wasn't crazy.
And so--
[LAUGHTER]
So I go there.
And we didn't have
an embassy there.
And we had no idea what
was going to happen.
So I'm sitting in
the guesthouse where
they had a camera and things
that to record your sound
and everything.
I hadn't realized
that when you type,
they can tell just by the
strokes what you're doing.
So we sat there waiting
for some kind of whatever.
And they said that I had to go
and see his embalmed father.
So that's much more
complicated than meets the eye.
Because if you bow too
low in front of his body,
then the American press
will criticize you
for being obsequious.
And if you don't bow low enough,
then it doesn't do the job.
Anyway, I must have
had the right angle
because I then go back to
the guesthouse and they said,
now the Dear Leader
will see you.
So we're at our press
conference which
was like something out of
the '50s with old cameras
and stuff.
And I'm standing
next to this man
and I see we're the same height.
And I know I had on high heels.
So I looked over at
him, and so did he.
And his hair was a
lot poofier than mine.
But the bottom line is
we had very serious talks
about-- at that
stage-- missile limits.
And then the election
of 2000 happened.
And I briefed Colin Powell
on what we were doing.
He was very interested in it.
And then a headline appeared
in the Washington Post
saying "Powell to continue
Clinton policies on North
Korea."
And he was hauled into the
Oval and told, "no way."
So I hold no brief
for the North Koreans.
But that was a very
unfortunate aspect of it.
But I think the point that you
were talking about is that--
I'm glad they're
having a meeting.
And the South
Koreans are clearly
playing an important role.
I am concerned about
the preparation.
I'm concerned that the State
Department has been hollowed
out and that the guy that
was their chief North Korean
specialist has left.
I'm glad that Pompeo
went to North Korea.
And I'm glad they're
having the meeting.
I'm concerned that a
meeting such as that
requires a great
deal of discipline
and how this is going to work.
There was an
interesting analysis
that I read last night
which says that if they have
a decent meeting, that
then an incredible amount
of diplomatic work is
going to have to be done.
And I don't quite know
how it's going to work.
By the way, the one thing that
we did know about the father--
and Dennis Rodman is all my
fault because what happened was
we knew that the father
liked basketball.
So I took over a
basketball autographed
by Michael Jordan, which
is in their holy of holies.
So maybe Dennis Rodman
will be part of this now.
But they're going to be
very complicated talks.
And just to add
another level to this,
President Macron of
France is here today.
I was watching the
arrival statement.
And it's very clear,
he made clear,
that the Iran agreement
and the North Korean talks
are linked together.
And they are because
the North Koreans are
going to need some agreement.
And if the president already
is prepared to tear up
the Iran agreement, why
would they go along with it?
So we'll see where
those two go together.
And by the way, it's a perfect
example of something there.
Everybody talks about
diplomacy as a chess game.
It is not a chess game.
Those are two people
sitting quietly,
figuring out their moves.
It's more like pool,
billiards, where
there's a bunch of balls
in the middle of the table,
somebody comes up
with a cue stick
with the hope of getting a ball
into a pocket on the other side
and it hits a lot of
other balls along the way.
It's very horizontal
and dynamic.
And I think we're seeing
all that right now
in terms of how one
thing affects another.
HEATHER YOUNG:
Beware of hustlers.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
Definitely beware.
Very good.
I'm going to add that.
HEATHER YOUNG: [LAUGHS]
So one of your previous books
is called "Read My Pins."
And so while we wait for
people to come up to the mic--
we'll be opening up for
questions in just a moment--
can you tell us a little bit
about how that got started?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
Yeah, I will.
So I clearly like jewelry.
So what happened was I got
to the UN in February of '93.
And the Gulf War had just ended.
And the cease-fire had been
translated into a series
of sanctions resolutions.
And my job was to make sure
the sanctions stayed on.
And so I said perfectly
horrible things
about Saddam Hussein every day.
He deserved it because
he invaded Kuwait.
So all of a sudden, there was
a poem in the papers in Baghdad
comparing me to many
things, but among them
an unparalleled serpent.
So I had a snake pin.
And I decided to wear it
whenever we talked about Iraq.
And you've seen how
the ambassadors go out
after one of their meetings
and the press is out there.
So all of a sudden, the cameras
zeros in and the reporter says,
why are you wearing
that snake pin?
And I said, because
Saddam Hussein compared me
to an unparalleled serpent.
And then I thought,
well, this is fun.
So I went out and I bought
a lot of costume jewelry
to reflect whatever we were
going to do on any given day.
And so I wore flowers,
and butterflies,
and balloons on good days.
And on bad days, I wore
carnivorous animals
and insects.
And the other
ambassadors kind of
had begun to figure
out what was going on.
And the first
President Bush had said
"read my lips-- no new taxes."
So I said, read my pins.
And people really
got used to it.
So one story, for instance--
when I was Secretary,
the Russians were bugging
the State Department.
And it was in an office
right near my office.
And we found the guy
listening outside.
And we did what diplomats do
which is dmarche Moscow--
"how could you
possibly do that?"
But the next time I met with
the Russian foreign minister
I wore a huge bug.
And he knew exactly
what I was doing.
[LAUGHTER]
So I see you've got on a pin.
HEATHER YOUNG: I
do, it's a Phoenix.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
That's very good.
And I have Mercury
the Messenger.
So that's what's going on.
AUDIENCE: Madam
Secretary, you've
been an inspiration to
both some of the most
incredible people in my life
and some of the most important.
And since they
can't be here today,
I just want to say thank you
on behalf of them and myself.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: Thank you.
Thank you so much
for saying that.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Secretary Albright,
thanks for being here today.
I actually was fellow in
your 2016 Albright Institute
at Wellesley College.
I wanted to ask how your
most recent book will impact
the 2019 Institute
at Wellesley College
and was wondering
if you could talk
a little bit about your
plans for how you're
going to continue that
relationship for how you're
mentoring some young millennials
from your alma mater.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: So
what class were you?
AUDIENCE: Class of 2017.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
2017-- and I'm
class of 1959, which means
I went to Wellesley sometime
between the invention of the
iPad and the discovery of fire.
[LAUGHTER]
But let me tell people-- what
happened was I loved Wellesley.
I had a great time there.
AUDIENCE: Me too.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: And they
established this Institute
in my name.
And what it does is train young
women in global leadership.
And the basis of it
is multidisciplinary.
So I was a poli sci major.
And I did take history.
And when I took economics,
that seemed out of my lane.
Now we know that international
relations is a growth industry
and that it requires people
that have a basis in science,
and religion, and archeology.
And so the Institute
at Wellesley-- we
choose somewhere between 40 and
50 Albright Fellows every year.
We're about to celebrate
our 10th anniversary.
And what we do is
these young women
are there between
semesters in groups
to present various programs.
And they have to
learn about each other
and the different disciplines,
and present projects
and speak publicly.
And I'm very excited about it.
We now have a whole
cohort of Albright Fellows
around the world.
And we're going to pursue this.
And we're just looking at what
the next set of things-- we've
been doing sustainable
development
goals or various things that
have something in common.
But I do think that--
the book, I'm hoping,
will be something that gets
people interested in what
creates the divisions
in the society and then
the institutions that
have to deal with them.
And how many of them are
institutions that are national
and how many are international?
So I'm very glad you're here.
That's what is
supposed to happen.
So--
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So my question has
to do with the warning you
have for us.
And the political
perspective that I
come from being
interested in civil rights
and being pro-choice,
and things like that.
For me, the phrase "states'
rights" has always sort of been
like a dirty phrase
because it's always
been associated with people
fighting against those things.
But to what extent do
you think federalism
is a defense against fascism?
Do you think that
federalism will save us?
Will the states save us?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: I think it's
a very interesting question.
Because at the moment,
they are saving us.
Because part of the
things that's happening--
first of all,
state legislatures,
despite the fact that many of
them are held by Republicans,
I do think that there
are various aspects that
are working.
And the state judicial
systems I find
fascinating in terms
of what they've
done to change the ban
against immigrants coming in.
And then also some of
the things in terms
of the investigations
that are going on that
are going to the states.
And I think to a
great extent, it's
interesting because we
always kind of thought
of states' rights
as backward-leaning.
One of the problems with
fascism is the centralization
of everything, the
centralization of the power.
Therefore, having some
dispersion through federalism
works.
What I think is
interesting also,
if one looks at what's
happening in Europe--
they're never going to have
a United States of Europe
and some form of
federalism, for them.
And that's what Macron has begun
to talk about more and more.
I think, again, it
provides some local input
and allows there to be a
different identity, which
is not exactly our
problem in the US.
But then also some way
of bringing it together
at the top.
So I do think most of us have
to change our view about it.
I know when states'
rights seemed
like a bunch of
Dixiecrats or something.
And so I do think that it's
a very interesting example
of change in this.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thank you, Madam Secretary.
[INAUDIBLE] My question is about
the role of income inequality
and oligarchy in growth
of authoritarian regimes.
I grew up in Russia.
In 1990s, Russian
society went a long way
from appearance of
equality to one of the most
unequal societies in the world.
And it created a lot of anger.
And oligarchs
channeled that anger
into putting in the power
of the authoritarian leader.
And from that perspective,
the authoritarian look
of Vladimir Putin was
a feature, not a bug.
Would you agree with
political groups
within the United States who
highlight income inequality
and growth of corporate
oligarchy power
as the biggest threat for
the United States democracy?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
Well, let me just
say something about Russia.
I used to be known
as a Soviet expert.
And I look at my
library and I think--
archeology it's not.
A lot of the things are germane
to what is going on now.
And I do have to mention
this because I talked
about the survey I did in '91.
We had questionnaires
and focus groups.
And we did them in Russia.
And I'll never
forget a focus group
that we had outside of Moscow
where this man stood up
and said, I'm so embarrassed.
We used to be a
superpower and now we're
Bangladesh with missiles.
And what has happened
is that Putin has really
identified himself with
that loss of identity,
and now has restored
Russia to its greatness.
And I think that that's frankly
one of the things that then
allows him to run a country
where inequality is very bad
and the oligarchs have
taken over in many ways.
The United States--
for the most part, I do
think that this economic
disparity is one
of the issues that's out there.
And the thing that has
happened is, I think, Trump--
it's a little weird for me.
Either he is a
billionaire or he isn't.
But the bottom line is, he
has identified himself, quote,
"with this group
of people that are
economically disadvantaged."
He also has done
something, which
is to talk about making
America great again.
I happen to think
America is great, that he
doesn't have to do that.
But I do think that the
economic disparity is
something that is part
of the danger of having
a demagogic leader who
says, I will fix it,
and this "us versus them" part.
So to that extent, I think
we are susceptible to that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So
historically, fascism
is usually associated with
the right-wing movements.
But it seems that according
to your definition,
it can also be applied to
certain left-wing phenomenon.
So what is your
assessment at present--
where is the danger
higher, left versus right?
And then with respect
to this difference,
how do you assess the US
versus the rest of the world?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
One of the things
is the leaders that
I have talked about,
even Orban, et cetera--
I am careful not to
say "he is a fascist."
The only real fascist
that's out there now
is in North Korea
where there is just
complete control
over everything.
And so that would lead me to
say that the leftist one is
more dangerous.
But I actually think that the
rightist one, at the moment,
is predominant.
Partially because
first of all, Orban
has made up this term
"illiberal democracy"
which is an oxymoron,
and trying to figure out
whether there are those--
particularly the
ones in Europe--
that have been against
leftists because they
think they're all communists.
And they do know what communism
did to their countries.
And so because I see
that threat primarily
in Central and Eastern Europe--
and then also
Venezuela, for instance.
But mostly from both
sides, but at the moment
I would say the right
is more dangerous.
AUDIENCE: And in
the US [INAUDIBLE]??
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
And In the US,
I think at the moment
it's more from the right.
And we can't keep
talking about it
in terms of the 2016 election.
But basically
because it was kind
of a movement against the
left identity politics,
or whatever people
were calling it.
And I do think--
but I may be totally wrong on
this because I think it's both.
And I think people have
been very surprised
that I included communists
and the left as fascists
because people usually
don't think of it that way.
But they were opposed
to each other.
But if you look at some
of the characteristics,
they're exactly the same.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming,
Madam Secretary Albright.
You mentioned checks
and balances earlier.
I had a question about
checks and balances
and our current president.
I think one of the
things that annoys me
about a lot of the
announcements of Trump
is that it kind of
pretends that there's
only one branch of
government where we actually
have three branches.
I know recently Trump lost an
immigration case in the Supreme
Court.
And the deciding vote was
actually his own nominee,
Justice Gorsuch.
And then I'm sure
there's also times
where Paul Ryan [INAUDIBLE]
politely or not-so
politely told Trump "no"
behind closed doors.
So in terms of
checks and balances,
do you think it's working well?
Do you think it's working
not well in the government?
What's the current state
of that in your opinion?
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT:
Well, I have,
again, not a
paradoxical situation.
I've been talking about the
resiliency of democracy,
and at the same time about
the fragility of democracy.
And we're kind of between
those two at the moment.
I do think that the checks and
balances are working better
with the judicial
system, frankly.
There's a case coming
up in the Supreme Court
now again on bans on immigrants.
And I think that there
are some interesting parts
that the Supreme Court is doing.
And I think earlier in my
answer on the states' rights,
I do think that some of the
judicial aspects of state
courts are doing work.
I am concerned about what's
happening in Congress.
Because I think that it is much
less into checks at the moment.
And they really have
not done that much.
One of the things that people
forget about democracy--
it's majority rule
and minority rights.
And there's not enough
emphasis about how
the minority in Congress
is able to operate
given the various rules.
So they look always as
if they are undermining,
that they're creating
the gridlock.
And so I am sometimes
suspicious about the fact
that it really strengthens
Trump that there's gridlock.
Because he can say they
aren't doing anything.
And so the question is whether
the non-Trump Republicans
and the Democrats can
somehow figure out
to have more things that
make the checks really work.
But I think that basically, I
have faith in our institutions.
And as I think I
said earlier, I don't
want to operate
on the fear factor
but on the hope factor, which
is why these elections in 2018
are so important and
why my to-do list is
for people that disagree--
the normalizing thing.
If they don't want to
see this normalized,
then we all have the power
to go out and change that.
And I mean, you all live
in the state of California.
I mean, in Washington,
next to California.
But I mean, the western coast
is really incredibly strong.
And. the state of
Washington has been
incredible on the
judicial stuff,
unbelievable in terms of the
strength of the judiciary.
So the combination
of the West Coast,
you in California and Oregon,
make a big difference.
The question is
whether you can push,
and that the rest of us in
the other parts of the country
can figure out how to
get a different Congress.
And believe me, I
think there is going
to be an awful lot of action
from the other side in terms
of making these elections
more complicated.
And the role of the
Russians in our elections--
I just was again
reading something.
The fact that the
president-- because he is
so concerned as to whether
he was elected legitimately
or not-- will not do something
about what happened in 2016
means that we are
still open to problems
in terms of undermining
this 2018 election.
And what is going to happen?
There are machines
in the United States
that are paperless, the
electronic machines.
And so I think
there's a lot of work
that needs to be done in that.
So we need to have the
checks and balances work.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much for coming
and speaking to us today.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I have to say--
believe me, I know I'm in the
great state of Washington.
Let me just say that I came
here for the first time,
as I said, to the
United States in 1948.
My father was a professor
at the University of Denver.
And in the summer
of 1950, he came
to teach at the
University of Washington.
So I was here in 1950.
And it was fantastic.
And I've come back
many times since.
And my daughter, who was a
public defender when they moved
here from the other Washington
where she had been defending
rapists and robbers.
And she called and said,
"mom"-- she was in Snohomish.
And she said,
"Mom, I'm defending
somebody who molested salmon."
[LAUGHTER]
But this is a fabulous state.
And I'm delighted to be here.
The salmon are feeling great.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you all very much.
AUDIENCE: There are still
some books for sale.